there's a number of reasons you'd be
potentially better off breaking your app
into different activities having a
single monolithic activity increases the
complexity of your code making the
creation and management of intent
filters much harder and making it more
difficult to maintain tests and read
your activity code it also increases the
risk of tightly coupling independent
components and makes it much more likely
to introduce security risks of a single
activity includes both sensitive
information and information that's safe
to share a good rule of thumb is to
create a new activity whenever the
context changes for example displaying a
different kind of data or switching from
viewing to entering data